تشير أوكرانيا إلى أن
هجومها المضاد الذي طال انتظاره يقترب مع
انتهاء الاستعدادات في التعليقات
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع.
لم يقدم الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي تاريخًا محددًا لبدء الهجوم
لأسباب واضحة، ولكن هناك شيء واحد
واضح أن هذه الخطوة من المرجح أن تمثل
لحظة محورية في أوكرانيا.  الحرب مع نيك بيتون والش من سي إن إن
مع المزيد من زاباريجا
بشأن الدلائل المتزايدة على أن
الهجوم المضاد لأوكرانيا شيء ذو
أهمية استراتيجية مطلقة بالنسبة لهم لكنهم
قالوا إنهم لن يعلنوا عن
بداية العلامات التي ربما تكون
مقدمة له أو حتى في حد ذاته
بدأت تجري خلال
الأسبوع الماضي، سمعنا تقارير عن انفجارات
في شرق أغنيتها المحتلة وعلى
طول ضفة
نهر دانيبرو التي تسيطر عليها روسيا، كانت هناك تقارير عن
احتمال هبوط القوات الأوكرانية
بأعداد صغيرة جدًا.  الإلهاء
هو أن هناك شيئًا ما في إيرنست أوكرانيا
حريص جدًا على عدم تأكيد أي من هذه
التقارير أو الإشارة إلى أن أي شيء
حاسم يجري ولكن في
الأيام الماضية شهدنا هجمات على نوفاكوفكا أه
بواسطة ضربات مدفعية أوكرانية
ربما تقضي على
البنية التحتية الروسية الرئيسية أيضًا في مليتا  استطلاع
آخر لمدينة روسية محتلة كانت هناك
تقارير عن انفجارات أيضًا، علاوة على ذلك
أيضًا، تعرض استطلاع سيلفستر في شبه
جزيرة القرم المحتلة لضربة بطائرة بدون طيار
وفقًا لمسؤولي الاحتلال الروسي
هناك مما تسبب في سلسلة مدمرة من
الانفجارات عبر مستودع حيوي للديزل
هناك.  يعد هذا أمرًا مهمًا
للوجود البحري الروسي في
شبه الجزيرة المحتلة، مما أدى إلى حدوث أضرار جسيمة استغرقت
ساعات من رجال الإطفاء لإخمادها،
ومثال آخر على كيفية قدرة أوكرانيا في
هذه المرحلة على ضرب أجزاء حيوية من
خط الإمداد الروسي في المناطق المحتلة،
الأمر الذي سيتسبب في خسائر فادحة في الأرواح.  لقد سمعنا
قدرة جيشها على العمل
للرد، سمعنا
تحذيرًا غريبًا من يفغينيا بريجوسيان، وهي
شخصية روسية عامة جدًا شاركت في
الحرب، يقول رئيس مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر،
وأعيد صياغته هنا،
إنهم يعانون من نقص شديد في الذخيرة التي يتم توفيرها
حول باك.  ناقش تلك المدينة الرمزية بأنهم
من المحتمل أن يضطروا إلى
الانسحاب أو تقليل قواتهم هناك
ما لم يوجهوا أصابع الاتهام بسرعة أكبر
بالتأكيد مرة أخرى إلى
قادة الدفاع الروس ويحذرون أيضًا من أنه
قد تكون هناك كارثة إذا
لم يفعلوا ذلك  وبالنظر إلى ما يحتاجون إليه بسرعة الآن، فقد
أصدرنا بيانات متنوعة من قبل
وقدمنا ​​القليل من الأدلة، ولكن من
الغريب أن نسمع هذا النوع من التحذير في
هذا الوقت بالذات عندما تواجه روسيا
تحركًا عسكريًا أوكرانيًا يحتمل أن يكون حاسمًا للغاية، ولا نعرف
متى سيحدث ذلك  لا نعرف أين
سيحدث ذلك ولكن من المؤكد أنه
بدأ في بناء المشاركة والقلق
والتوتر الذي ينتظره نيك
بيتون والش سي إن إن زاباريزيو أوكرانيا
وينضم إلي الآن اللواء المتقاعد
بالجيش الأسترالي ميك رايان وهو أيضًا
قائد سابق في الجيش الأسترالي.
كلية الدفاع الأسترالية ومؤلف كتاب "الحرب
حولت مستقبل القرن الحادي والعشرين،
المنافسة والصراع بين القوى العظمى"،
من الجيد دائمًا رؤيتك يا مكة، ما الذي يجعل
هذا الهجوم المضاد عندما
يبدأ يبدو من حيث الأهداف
والتكتيكات،
حسنًا، حسنًا يا مايكل، أعتقد أن ما نفعله  "
لن نرى دفعة كبيرة واحدة، سنرى
الكثير من
الهجمات المختلفة في مناطق مختلفة
وسيرغب الأوكرانيون في إرباكهم للخداع
لمفاجأة الروس بشأن
المكان الذي قد تكون جهودهم الرئيسية فيه ولكن
أيضًا حول مكان لوجستياتهم"
قوتهم النارية وكل هذه الأشياء التي
تدعم هجماتهم هي ما
ناقشناه أنت وأنا في بداية
الصراع ولدينا شعور أيضًا
بأن الاستيلاء على الأراضي يختلف عن
السيطرة على الأراضي نظرًا لأن ما ستفعله بعد ذلك
سيكون المعيار الرئيسي
للنجاح  وأنا أعلم أن هناك أكثر من
نعم بالتأكيد أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى
رؤية واضحة لما سيبدو
كهجوم ناجح أولاً،
يحتاج الأوكرانيون إلى استعادة
أراضيهم ويريدون تحرير
مواطنيهم واستعادة
أراضيهم السيادية لكنهم  "سيتعين علينا أيضًا
الاستيلاء على القوات الروسية أو تدميرها لضمان
عدم تمكن الروس من شن
هجمات مضادة أو تشكيل تهديد مستقبلي
لبقية هذا العام. أخيرًا،
سيتعين على الأوكرانيين التأكد من أن
شعبهم وأيضًا السياسيين
والمواطنين  في الغرب يرون
هجومًا ناجحًا، لذا سيتعين عليهم
إيصال ما يجري
وتوصيل هجوم ناجح في
هذا الواقع، نعم لمواصلة هذا
الدعم الغربي المهم للغاية مقابل
لا شيء آخر. روسيا عرفت روسيا أن
هذا سيأتي بالطبع و  لقد أمضوا
الكثير من الوقت في تعزيز الدفاعات،
ومجموعة من الحواجز، وهناك
شبكات الخنادق الضخمة التي رأيناها بشكل خاص
على طول الجبهة الجنوبية، وقد أعادوا
تسليحهم، وهكذا كيف يبدو
الموقف الروسي فيما يتعلق
بالدفاع عن هذا الهجوم المضاد
بشكل جيد  الشيء الوحيد في كل هذه
الأعمال الدفاعية التي قاموا بها
هو أنها ثابتة، ومن السهل
التقاطها، ومن السهل استهدافها بالذخائر
الدقيقة، كما أنها
جيدة بقدر القوات التي تحرسها
إذا  إنهم يراقبون العوائق
ويغطونها بالنيران المباشرة وغير المباشرة،
وهذا هو الحال بالنسبة للبعض
منهم، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أن الروس سيكون
لديهم أيضًا احتياطيات متنقلة والتي
من المحتمل أن يرغب الأوكرانيون في
استهدافها قبل الهجمات،
وقد يكون ذلك  بعض هذه الانفجارات التي
شهدناها خلال الأسبوع الماضي، نعم، من
المثير للاهتمام أنك ذكرتها في
البداية ودعنا نتحدث
أكثر عنها، كما تعلم على الرغم من
الدفاعات الروسية المثيرة للإعجاب،
أعني أنه من العدل أن نقول إنها
جيدة  نظرًا لأن القوات التي تشغل تلك
المواقع والضباط الذين يقودونها من
الحكمة ولكن أيضًا من الحكمة المعنوية
التي تحدثت عنها من قبل،
وهذه هي المجالات التي
فشلت فيها روسيا بانتظام خلال الحرب،
نعم لقد فشلوا بالتأكيد
ولم يتحسنوا  كما
حدث جميعًا، أعني أن القوات المعبأة هي
أقل جودة من العديد من أولئك الذين
غزوا أوكرانيا في البداية، وهذه
القوات تعرف أنها لا تدافع عن
وطنها، ولا تدافع عن
شعبها أو مدنها، بل
الدفاع عن الأراضي التي تم الاستيلاء عليها بشكل
غير قانوني حتى تعلم أن دوافعهم
للبقاء والقتال أه سيكون موضع
تساؤل وسيكون من
المثير للاهتمام معرفة المدة التي ستستغرقها قبل أن
تنكسر الدفاعات الروسية قبل هطول
أمطار النار والفولاذ
عليهم من الأوكرانيين
يتطلب الهجوم الكبير الأسلحة ولكننا
سمعنا أيضًا أن أوكرانيا طالبت بمزيد من
الأسلحة ولكن في الوقت نفسه
كانوا يستخدمونها بمعدل مذهل
فقط يبقون الروس في مأزق
خاصة في الشرق، هل لديهم
المواد؟  للقيام بدفعة مستدامة
وهل يعرفون كيفية استخدامها بشكل
جيد، فقد تلقوا بالتأكيد الكثير من
المواد على مدار الـ 14 شهرًا الماضية،
وبينما استخدموا الكثير منها، تعلم أن
القائد الأعلى يخدع في
في مقابلة أجريت معه في ديسمبر أوضح أن
هناك أيضًا مواد تدقيق
للهجمات القادمة، كما أنهم
تلقوا الكثير منذ عيد الميلاد وكانوا
يتدربون بسرعة والشيء الوحيد الذي
أثبته الأوكرانيون منذ
بداية هذه الحرب هو
أنهم  "إنها دراسات سريعة جدًا، فهم سريعون في
استيعاب أسلحة جديدة ومعدات جديدة
واستخدامها بطرق مبتكرة قد
لا نفكر فيها، وأعتقد أنهم
سيفاجئوننا ويفاجئوننا بشكل سار
في الروس بشكل غير سار في هذه
الهجمات القادمة